Japan has no military.
What it has, the government insists, are self-defense
forces.
Whatever you call them, Japan has $49 billion
a year worth — more than all but eight other
countries.
Officially, likewise, Japan is staunchly opposed
to any and all nuclear proliferation,
Yet in 2017, it refused to ratify a UN non-proliferation
treaty.
It also maintains a curiously large stockpile
of plutonium.
And America’s nuclear weapons are a key
component of its defense.
Neither, finally, does it build aircraft carriers.
This, clearly, is only a “helicopter destroyer”.
For the last 70 years, the world’s now third-largest
economy has waged not a single war, nor fired
a single shot in combat.
In 1977, its Prime Minister labeled the nation’s
commitment to peace a “historically unprecedented
experiment”.
In a world where “big country” is synonymous
with “big military”, Japan has somehow
remained an almost singular beacon of hope
in an alternative.
But, in the face of rising threats from neighboring
China, North Korea, and Russia, many would
argue it’s only a matter of time before
Japan becomes a, quote, “normal” country.
Indeed, some would say it already has — in
everything but name.
The truth, however, is far more complicated.
Sponsored by Morning Brew — the free, daily
newsletter that keeps you up to date on the
world of tech and business.
Translating an abstract concept like “peace”
into the words of a legal document is already
ambitious,
But the idea that an authoritarian, militaristic
state could be transformed into a free, democratic,
and peaceful one simply by transplanting an
entire value system like Pacifism, is downright
absurd.
Yet that’s exactly what the Americans attempted
after Japan’s unconditional World War II
surrender.
As the U.S. beg an writing Japan’s post-war
constitution, General Douglas MacArthur made
three initial demands: One of which prohibited
the country from ever engaging in war, even
for self-defense.
Its continued existence would depend entirely
on the protection of others.
In the end, a slightly more ambiguous phrasing
was adopted in the final draft of its Constitution,
known as Article 9:
“the Japanese people forever renounce war
as a sovereign right of the nation … land,
sea, and air forces, as well as other war
potential, will never be maintained.”
Note the omission of the words “self-defense”.
Although the spirit of the constitution remained
as originally intended, its letter now left
what would eventually become a $49 billion
a year loophole.
Perhaps the only surprise was just how quickly
it was exploited.
Less than five years after America hand-wrote
Japan’s Pacifist constitution, who pressured
its militarization, but… the Americans!
The peace constitution came into effect in
1947.
In 1949, the Communist Party took control
of China.
And in 1950 the Korean War began.
In only a matter of months, Japan went from
being seen as an extreme threat that could
only be suppressed with equally strong force,
to a valuable asset in the fight against Communism.
When U.S. soldiers were sent to fight in Korea,
Japan was left unprotected, leading to the
creation of the 75,000-person National Police
Reserve.
Officially, the Police Reserve was not responsible
for external security, thus not an army, and,
thus, constitutional.
Equipment left by the U.S. military, like
tanks, were labeled with euphemisms like “special
vehicles”.
Two years later, the Police Reserve became
the Safe ty Force, which the Prime Minister
insisted still had no “war potential”.
And two years after that it graduated to become
the Japanese “Self-Defense Forces”, which
have now survived decades of constitutional
challenges.
It would be a mistake, however, to call its
armed forces a “normal” military in everything
but name.
While not weak, they are, nevertheless, severely
constrained.
They do not, for instance, benefit from conscription,
and therefore struggle to fill positions.
Neither can they possess certain offensive
weapons such as intercontinental ballistic
missiles.
It’s fair to say Japan has performed all
kinds of mental and linguistic gymnastics
in justifying things like its non-“aircraft
carrier” aircraft carrier.
But it would be also an exaggeration to say
it can acquire any weapon or behave like any
other military.
It may stretch the limits, sometimes rather
flagrantly, but there are still limits.
Now, Article 9 could, in theory, be amended.
Changing the constitution requires two-thirds
support in both houses of the Diet, its legislative
body, plus a simple majority in a public referendum.
But this has never been accomplished in its
entire 74-year existence.
It is, in fact, the world’s oldest unchanged
constitution.
The real obstacle is not so much legal as
it is cultural.
To understand why, it helps to understand
Pacifism not as a value forced upon Japan
by American occupiers, but as a product of
the war itself.
While the U.S. may wish to claim responsibility,
identifying the real cause is vital to measure
its durability.
Legal documents can change, but framing the
issue only as a legal one distracts from the
cultural impediment, which is much harder
to change.
Over 3 million Japanese lives were lost in
World War II.
20% of all homes were destroyed.
And, of course, it suffered from the only
use of nuclear weapons on a human population
in war.
Faced with this immense psychological toll,
it’s said that Japanese society developed
several coping mechanisms: First, the need
to assign meaning to an otherwise senseless
loss of life.
And second, to preserve one’s sense of innocence,
the shifting of all blame onto the institution
of the military.
To resist militarization, in other words,
was to recognize and learn from the past,
while relieving oneself of agency — whether
justified or not.
In the decades since, Japan also came to associate
peace with prosperity.
Its economy swiftly recovered and brought
with it a dramatic rise in quality of life.
What keeps these principles alive so many
years later is, in large part, education.
The Teacher’s Union, for example, though
less prominent than it once was, has resisted
efforts to reform curriculum.
Academia also acts as a strong check against
militarization.
In China, the line between academic and military
is so often blurred that the American government
can very easily find grounds to reject and
sometimes harass nearly any Chinese academic.
Most researchers around the world would have
a hard time saying ‘no’ to funding.
In Japan, however, universities explicitly
ban “dual-use” grants — civilian technologies
which also have some military application.
This deeply-ingrained skepticism isn’t confined
to any single segment of society.
Nearly every student has taken a field trip
to one of the country’s 76 peace museums,
which are spread out across 32 prefectures.
Over 74 million people in total have visited
the Hiroshima Peace Memorial Museum alone.
Regrettably, some museums gloss over Japan’s
own actions during the war, and few, if any,
challenge America’s involvement since, but
each and every one leaves visitors with a
strong revulsion to war.
When taken together, all these influences
create a distinct sentiment among the public.
But it can’t quite be labeled “Pacifism”,
and not just because no single ideology can
possibly describe 125 million people.
The word “Pacifism”, by the strictest
definition, means a total rejection of violence
— including self-defense.
It also implies a universal and coherent guiding
philosophy — yet human beings are complicated.
Some, who argue its defense forces are inadequate
for the times, say that while the Japanese
public supports the right to self-defense
in theory, they oppose its implementation
in practice.
On one hand, a clear majority — 78% in one
poll — say going to war is legitimate when
attacked.
Yet almost no one is willing to do so.
88% of Chinese citizens say they’re willing
to fight for their country, 77% of Taiwanese,
67% of South Koreans, but only 13% of Japanese.
The result is a massive divide between the
goals of the current Conservative government
and the attitudes of the public at large.
Unable to amend the constitution, the former
Prime Minister Abe Shinzo instead relied on
reinterpretation.
The basic argument goes something like this:
Most people believe Japan ought to maintain
at least the minimum level of force required
for self-defense.
The question is what that level is.
Conservatives argue that while defense expenditures
have been on the rise across East Asia, Japan’s
have remained more or less the same, at about
1% of GDP.
In this view, a stable military budget actually
means declining power in the context of adversaries
who are increasing theirs.
They also contend that global expectations
have changed.
Failure to prevent violence, wherever it occurs,
is no longer perceived as neutrality but tacit
approval, or, at least, shameful inaction.
In policy terms, this means actively maintaining
peace, whether in its own neighborhood or
the Middle East.
Abe Shinzo called this “Proactive Pacifism”.
Critics call it not Pacifism, suggesting it
represents a wholesale rejection of the Peace
Constitution and marks a new era of militarization.
But it’s important to contextualize these
changes.
The proposed constitutional amendment was
to explicitly allow the existence of self-defense
forces — something Japan already has.
If the public strongly opposed even that linguistic
change, it will almost certainly resist anything
more tangible.
Imagine, for a second, that a concept like
“Peace” could be measured on a single
continuum.
If Pacifism were on one side, on the other
would be Militarization — when a society
becomes aggressively consumed by the military
— think North Korea.
In the middle would be quote “normal”
countries — those that proudly possess militaries
and are reasonably willing to use them.
Japan may be trending in one direction, but
it has not yet reached even normalcy.
As the Conservative government passes security
laws, reinterprets Pacifism, and buys new
equipment, it may seem as though the future
is inevitable.
Yet the basic tension remains:
The current government defines Pacifism as
a verb — an action, the absence of which
would enable violence, whereas the majority
of the public think of it as an adjective
— a neutral state of being, if you will.
Is Proactive Pacifism only a polite, populace-pleasing
euphemism for militarization, or is it a modern
update to a 70-year old ideal?
To answer this question, we must finally address
the elephant in the room: The U.S. security
guarantee.
In reality, Pacifism is not just a negotiation
between politicians and voters — there’s
a third party — the United States Government
— and this relationship will determine its
future — next time, in Japan’s Pacifist
Paradox.
But first, if you’re like me, you like to
stay up to date on tech and business, but
find traditional news boring and unrelatable.
Morning Brew is a free, daily newsletter delivered
straight to your inbox.
It’s like having an executive assistant
who stays up all night working while you sleep.
When you wake up, you have a summary of the
most important and most interesting news of
the day waiting for you.
It’s quick, to-the-point, and perfect for
anyone who enjoys watching these videos.
Personally, my favorite part are the interesting
links at the bottom — it’s how I’ve
discovered topics for videos, good books to
read, and just fun articles that I’d otherwise
never find on my own.
You can sign up in about 15 seconds by clicking
the link on screen right now.
It’s completely free and all you need is
an email address.
So go sign up right now and start your day
off right with Morning Brew.